hi I'm Rudy Washington otherwise known
as the soxhlet and today I'm giving out
socks to the homeless people on this
very cold day in Detroit
[Music]
thank you god bless you thank you thank
you I never knew the definition of the
word bone-chilling until recently but
you got to keep your feet warm and
drunkest I'm a diabetic so I really need
socks it only takes one man to change
the world remember that it comes from
the heart comes from right here that's
what makes the man my mom and I were
sitting on the couch and she was
scrolling on Facebook and it said socks
are the most needed but the least
donated and that really broke my heart
and I was like hey mom can we start a
sock on
how are you Laurie
[Music]
god bless you - it's not about me that's
somebody's mom dad sister brother I just
want to give you another pair of socks
you never know how much you have until
you lose what you have
you